después del Carbón y el petróleo el
turno le llegó al diesel este domingo
entra en vigor la prohibición de la
Unión Europea de importar Diesel de
Rusia y el bloque impone también desde
hoy un tope de precios a la venta de
este y otros derivados del petróleo ruso
a terceros países el precio máximo por
barril para los productos Ultra
refinados como la gasolina y el diesel
ahora es de 100 dólares y el precio
máximo para los productos menos
refinados como el full oil es de 45
dólares por barril la medida apunta no
solo a compradores de esos productos
sino a navieras y aseguradoras el
objetivo en palabras de la presidenta de
la comisión europea Úrsula fonderline es
debilitar aún más la economía rusa para
que Vladimir Putin pague un alto costo
por la guerra en Ucrania
junto con nuestros socios del g7 hemos
adoptado nuevos límites de precios para
los productos petrolíferos rusos
transportados por mar como el diesel y
el fue el óleo esta decisión afectará
aún más los ingresos de Rusia y reducirá
su capacidad para librar la guerra en
Ucrania
la medida incluye un periodo de gracia
de 55 días siempre y cuando Los buques
hayan cargado El crudo en los puertos
antes del 5 de febrero la decisión ha
generado inquietudes sobre su eventual
impacto en los precios de estos
productos en el mercado mundial
los topes de los precios para los
productos derivados del petróleo y el
petróleo crudo serán monitoreados
continuamente por asegurar su
efectividad de impacto los límites de
los precios en sí mismos se revisarán y
ajustarán según corresponda
el embargo especialmente al diesel
implica un gran reto logístico para
Europa el 40% de las importaciones
comunitarias de este carburante
provenían de Rusia antes de la guerra